everybody to be part of here for Team
Coco outside of Tom Arnold's resting
room I don't get along with Tom so let's
see how that plays into this there we go
hello Jimmy Pardo here hello Tom young
man I'm gonna ask you to leave the room
because there's a good chance this comes
to fisticuffs well you know I'm a huge
fan of yours thank you buddy thank you
all right I bring it you know what I'm
out there and bring it and then I have
to take it down to come on you know a
good steps cameras bad down there the
juice but it's it's your camera no
offense I'll try to get it back up again
what's happening hey buddy how are you
good there's the deal now you're hosting
this new program my redneck hats what's
it call red redneck hats was the
original name but it's redneck vacation
we do just one episode and it's out of
force because there's only one redneck
hat so John Deere the one and maybe
there's an orange one you know for
hunting Caesars we could add a couple
episodes but this is a yeah it's a
people and we put them in the Hamptons
some rednecks from Louisiana and they're
there all summer and we see what happens
they mix it up
here's an idea I once saw a video you're
doing this redneck program I guess saw a
video of two rednecks and they were
playing rock paper scissors and whoever
won two out of three got the punch the
other guy in the face as hard as he
could yeah I'm gonna do that with you
all right let's do it
one two three well I don't like these
dig out okay that's one oh well I felt
like you went down a little bit if we
see the tape but we had a replay you
kind of went down it's like you were
seeing I did and you know right you put
your hand up okay I can tell you I can
tell you did not okay I believe you
that's what I believe you I believe you
I mean I got to get in your head see
what you're up to
okay I got it okay ready ready ready one
two three
all right I need okay one two three all
right be the face ready yeah
you
[Music]